[موسيقى]
الماضي
الماضي يعتبر النور بدوينا دربنا نحو طريق
التنميه الذاتيه نحن الماضي منتعلم جدا
كمان نطول من انفسنا وتعلم التجاربنا
متحدثنا التالي من قصر الماني واستقرت
بعده دول بالشرق الاوسط واشتهرت بفن تطريز
واعمال الانسانيه شاركونا بتتوك مميز
بعنوان عبره الماضي ومدى تاثيرها المستقبل
مع الفنانه هايكي
[تصفيق]
مساء الخير
انا اول اشي بدي اقول للشباب لنظموا هذا
مؤتمر
برافو عليكم يعني شغله كتير كتير منظم
وكثير كتير حلو واختيار المواضيع وهيك
حسيته كتير انتو موافقين
بهذا الشيء وطبعا يعني
للدعمني اجا يعني دائما كل اشي بده دعم
شويه بس انتم بتستاهلوا
فانا هلا اليوم بدي احكي شويه عن تاريخ
سوريا
بقول لكم ليش
قبل كل اشي انا عايشه هون بسوريا من 41
سنه يعني اكثر من اغلبكم انتم
فانا بدي احكي معك
كسوريه اقبلوا انه انا بحكي معكم كالسوريه
لما انا اجيت لهون للسوريا انا استغربت
قال الناس انا حبيت الناس كتير لقيتهم
منفتحين
وعيين
عندهم
تفكير علمي يعني وانا بعدين قلت طب من وين
هذا اذا انت بتروح انا جايه هون كاجنبيه
لهون وكله مستقبلوني كلهم يعني كانوا حتى
كمان بدهم يعرفوا شو كيف انتم عايشين وهيك
يعني كان في نوع من الفضول بدهم يتعرف
لما انت بتروح على قريه بالمانيا كسوري
يعني طلعوا عليك اول اشي هيك يعني ابصر شو
هذا وهيك يعني انا حسيت هون بالسورية
بالعكس ليش هذا هيك
يعني لقيت الجواب بالتاريخ بلاد الشام كان
دائما منتقى صغيره بعيش من بين امبرتوريات
كبيره كان بالشرق السومريين الاشوريين الى
اخره بجنوب كان الفرعانه وبالشمال كان اول
اشي بعدين العثمانيين الى اخره وهذا
المنطقه كان دائما ممالك صغيره كتير
ما بكتروا يدافعوا عن حالهم على طريق
الهرب اذا بيجي للجيوش احنا خلص ضل قاعدين
خليهم يجوا هدول بيجوا وبيروحوا كمان لانه
احنا ما نقدر بس احنا نقدر نستخدم
نعتمد على شغلتين عرضنا
والانسان
كثره الانسان على
اختراعات قدره الانسان على تاقلم كثره
الانسان على
بتعامل مع كل بكل مرحله جديده بطريقه
جديده
فمن هون دلت المنطقه دائما مستقله رغم انه
يعني احيانا كانوا يجوا ويروحوا يجوا
يختلوا المنطقه ويروحوا مره ثانيه بس تل
المنطقه دائما مستقله وكان رغم انه ممالك
صغيره كانوا يعتمدوا على حالهم واكثر اشي
صاروا سياسيين ممتازين لانه هذا بيحتاج
لسياسه ممتازه اذا بدك دلت مستقله بين
بريطانيات كبيره
فصاروا سياسيين كتير صار عندهم
اهميه التجاره لانه عبر التجاره بقدر
يعملوا الى قاعات بدون ما يستفزه هذا انه
يحجم عليهم وانا ما بعرف اذا انتم بتعرفوا
انه بالفرع قبل
3,500 سنه كانه ياخذوا مطرزات من سوريا
كان من وقتها البيع المطرزات السوريه فهون
بالمنطقه كانوا يعني
كانت يعني دائما بيشتغلوا على حالهم
الفنيسيين
طوروا صنعه السفن عشان يطوروا التجاره
الابجديه كمان
فكروا فيها هون او بلشوا فيها هون لانه
كمان كانت الموضوع الاتصال بين بعض
الاتصال
التجاره والاتصال الثقافي بين بعد
من هون انا بعتقد انه احنا فينا نتعلم من
هذا الشيء
يعني احنا كمان سوريا بلد صغيره بين
حواليهم يعني محيط في
يعني ناس اللي بيشدوا من هون والناس اللي
بيشدوا من هون
كبيره اللي بيشدوا من هون ومن هناك فاحنا
لازم نعتمد على هاينا ولازم نعتمد على على
الارض وعلى الشعب هذا الشغلتين اللي احنا
لازم يعني اللي فينا نعتمد عليها
احنا لما
بلشت بالمشغل عنات ب 1988 حطينا ثلاث
احداث قلنا الاول هدف انشغال اليد العامله
لانه كان في كثير نساء ما بشتغلوا يعني
بشتغلوا بالبيت طبعا يعني بشتغلوا اكثر من
الرجال يمكن بس ما عندهم
شغل معترف فيها كشغل منتج
وبجيب مصاري بالاخر
فهذا انشغال اليد العامله وتطوير هذا
الامكانيات امكانيات النساء بهذا المجال
الهدف الثاني كان الحفاظ على التراث لانه
التراث كنز قلنا هذا خلق خلقوا الاجيال
قبلنا واحنا فينا نستفيد منه فيها هدم
كتير فيها خبره فيها
شغلات احنا نبني
عليها عليها اليوم
واحنا ما كنا بدنا نحفظ نحافظ على التراث
مش بس بالمتحف كشيله راح وهلا احنا بنحطه
بالمتحف ونطلع عليها انا دائما بقول
المتحف المقبره الحضاره لا احنا بدنا هذا
عرب الدال
حيوي بيناتنا
فهذا الهدف الثاني والهدف الثالث
كان انه طيب اذا احنا نصنع هيك شي ونعرضه
للعالم بلكي نكسب كمان اصدقائي يشوفوا
شعبنا اللي كانوا دائما يمكن يشوفوا بس من
زاويه السياسيه بشوفها منشوفوه هناك كمان
من زاويه حضاريه اكثر
وبنكسب استقاله لشابنا هيك احنا بلشنا
نشتغل
ورحنا الى القرى
قبل الحرب كان عنا اكثر من الف امراه بكل
سوريا اللي بيشتغلوا معنا لما رحنا للكره
اكتشفنا يمكن فرجيناه شويه صور انا جبت
لكم شويه صور عشان تعرفوا شلون لما انا
بقول على القرى
فقيره كتير يعني الناس عايشين حياه بسيطه
كتير بس عندهم فن يعني
ما كنت اتخيل يعني بالنسبه للتدريس كانوا
يطرزوا لوحات
وبيعرفوا يحطوا الالوان بيعرفوا يشكلوا
اللوحه بالطريقه زي ما بندرس بالجماعات من
يعني من
خبرتهم من جيل ورا جيل تعلموا هذا الشيء
فانا اشتغلت مع مع النساء
وما قدروا
يتوروا حياتهم كمان اول اشي صار عندهم ثقه
بالنفس النساء يعني صار انتم المصاري
بجيبتهم صاروا النساء يشتروا خرفان
يبنوا غرفه جديده ببيتهم يعني هذا اللي
بسموها بيت هاي القبه واحد غرفه او فتحوا
دكانه بالقريه
فحسوا انه
احنا من من طاقتنا فينا
نخلق اشي وبدنا فينا نطوره حياتنا للاسف
الحرب طبعا قطع هذا الطريق لو دلينا
بنشتغل هيك كان طورت هدول الضيوف هدول
الكره بس اليوم الكره تقريبا كلهم مدمر
مدمره
اللي مش مدمر بكون مسروق الناس ما بقدر
يرجعوا لانه ما عندهم شبابيك ابواب اسلاك
كهرباء كل اشي مسروق
يعني حياتهم هلق اللاجئين
صار يعني كتير كتير صعب اغلبهم لاجئين
داخل سوريا بالمنطقه هوليهم في بعضهم
بالتركيه في في لبنان وفي
يعني اغلبهم بالتركيه ولبنان في بعضهم
بهالطريقه المانيا
انا بعتقد انه هلا احنا بلشنا نشتغل مره
ثانيه انا عملت معرض ذكرى
لشغلهم قبل سنتين
وهم شافوا بالتلفزيون
السوشيال ميديا
واعرفوا اني انا لسه موجود واتصلوا فيه
وتعالي بدنا الشغل فهلا احنا بلشنا نشتغل
مرات تاني
نتمنى انه نكمل الشغل بس في شغله ثانيه
كمان بدي اقول لكم احنا
كسوريين عايشين هلا الوضع انه جزء من
الشعب هون جزء من الشعب بره الشباب كلهم
بدهم يعني كثير منهم مش كلهم كثير منهم
بدهم يتركوا البراد
وبدهم يطلعوا لبرا
هذا هون انا دائما بذكرني بالشعب
الفلسطيني كمان الشعب الفلسطيني كان مطلوب
48 بس كان بيشتغلوا بالذكاء على تراثهم
وعلى الهويه الوطنيه لانه
لازم
الربطه بين الشاب بالداخل والشابلي عايش
بره فهذا
الفلسطينيه وهذا فينا نتعلم منهم علملوهم
عبر تراثهم يعني صاروا الناس
بالمخيمات
بتضف
وبالداخل فلسطين صاروا يطرزوا
الناس بره صاروا يشتروا هذول
يعرضوا على الناس بفرجوا الناس انا
فلسطيني دلل الفلسطينيه فلسطينيه فاحنا
هلا كمان في عنا كتير ناس برا
هدول لازم احنا نعطيهم اشي لحتى بقدر
يعبروا عن بلد بلدهم بره فهذا يعني هي
الشغلات اللي احنا نصنعه هلا وقلنا هلا
معرض دائما
بنبيع كتير
شغلات اللي الناس بياخذوا لبرا
واهميه انه الترابط بين الشعب الداخل
والشاب برا هاي
بيعطينا عمل للمستقبل انتم بتعرفوا انه
كتير في سوريين حتى كمان اجانب بيجوا لهون
احيانا وبيعملوا عمليات دكاتر ويعملوا
عمليات يعني بيعطونا علمهم
فاحنا لازم هذا التبادل يدل
فلازم ننظم هذا الشيء انا بفهم انه
في كثير شباب يطلعوا لبرا بس لازم احنا
نخليه الهبل ممدود بين السوري بالداخل
وسوري برا
وشكرا لكم
[تصفيق]